hey Peter Ruben net wired as part of our
exclusive look at the new Xbox console
so just got done putting the Kinect
sensor through its paces and seeing all
of its improved capabilities but it's
time to relax with a little television
but one of my kind of pet peeves about
television as I watch it now is I know a
few channels I know a few channels but
let's say it's Monday night Monday Night
Football is about to start and I have no
idea what my ESPN channel is what can I
do
well actually Peter we have you covered
you don't have to remember what channel
it's on anymore you can just say Xbox
channel 13 ESPN your program guide is
available no matter what you're doing on
the console so whether you're playing
halo whether you're watching TV whether
you're watching some other video content
you can always say xbox show guide and
the program guide will come up right on
top but the ability to snap in another
application is that something that we
have going now yeah we can totally show
that Xbox go home Xbox snap live TV and
the idea here is that you know in this
in the sidebar that we have will also
give you access to the channels that
you've used recently so now I know that
also Skype is a big part of the Xbox
environment and it's something you guys
are really excited about as kind of a
move to real video chat with it with the
new Kinect sensor yeah exactly with the
Kinect sensor in the living room we've
got an HD camera we've got a microphone
so that everyone can talk and we're
really excited about putting Skype
together with live TV have the video
call going in snap while you're still
watching TV and then tell your friend to
hey you know Kobe's going wild in the
fourth quarter or time to turn it on as
you can do that and then you can
continue to watch the game together with
Skype video call while you're watching
the game so obviously this is an early
build but my team is working around the
clock every day trying to make this
better and better a day over day we've
come a super long way in seven months
you're not even gonna believe what you
see leadership thank you so much Ben
Smith and Ashley Spiker and live TV on
the new Xbox there's a lot
to check out so we're gonna see what's
next